[Music]  [Music]  what is this tell us one of the most  advanced a eyes in the world he's an  early version of the project I'm working  on what do you want for me I need you to  complete the project and what if I say  no then your stay in my home will be  brief and unpleasant do everything Tao  says I have been instructed to inflict  pain should you not comply with my  commands he will complete these tasks  it's it's time to begin she just leave  what a ponies to find us you look at our  down here no one was coming to save us  how do we get out what is this  Julia Julia what are you doing  answer me  you have to let me go return to your  tasks immediately or I will inflict pain  [Music]